the greatest of all time here we go the
Epic Trilogy fight for the first time
ever Demetrius Johnson defends the one
flyweight World Championship in the USA
one fight night 10. Johnson versus
Marias three on Prime video
I I do think it's a very tough fight for
Henry cejudo at his age if you look at
the odds odds are not on his side at his
age and going for a title shot I'll give
you my picks right now I'll take let me
see it chin
uh I'm taking the dogs here now listen
I'm taking the dogs if I wanted to be on
the side of Kosh and make sure I'm right
so you guys you know take my my pick
serious I can do that that's what every
other show you watch is gonna do that's
not what I do
what is up famo it is May 1st May 1st
Cinco De Mayo's coming up I'm gonna be
my girl's birthday too yay Cinco de Mayo
NB day a lot of Mexican culture going on
at the crib right now kids balls deep in
soccer they keep losing complete waste
of my time anyway what's going on big
fight week fam big fight week you know
it's a big fight week when even firing
the kid has some fight news on it we uh
it will be up uh pretty soon it will be
uh we had chatri on and Mikey
Messi who is the Jiu Jitsu Phenom the
the the young man who doesn't look like
he could beat you up but he definitely
can we have them on finding the kid one
of my favorite shows we've done Chen
it was fantastic uh Chachi is just an
absolute Gem of of a human being and
such a great backstory so that will be
on firing the kid with Brian Callan and
you have uh chatri and Mikey on there
and uh yeah one championship this Friday
in my hometown Denver Colorado it's
actually in Broomfield to be uh
specifically be specific there it's at
the First Bank Center which I fought in
many of times when I was a young pup
coming up so it's gonna be great to come
back and check out one Championship I've
heard nothing but great things as far as
the production goes and uh listen the
UFC card UFC 288 is is good it's
freaking good man and I would pay just
to see uh Muhammad Gilbert Burns Al Joe
Henry sahudo uh Steamroller and Drew
Dober take my money the rest of cards
it's okay it's it's it's solid I think
we're a little spoiled because the the
pay-per-views have been so stacked this
is a quality card so I see some you know
some complaining going on online there
but I think you guys are off on those
things swing a great card especially
when you get a steamroller uh versus
Drew Dover for free that's the main
event on the prelims on ESPN so overall
it's a good card
um but I would I don't think this is out
of pocket here I would argue that one
championships card in their first time
breaking ground in the United States in
Denver Colorado is actual from top to
bottom is a better card
better card overall uh your headliner
um this is what's getting most the
attention is Demetrius Johnson the pound
for pound goat for a lot of people uh in
his rubber match right rubber match
fight against uh Adriano Marais and so
they're one and one and uh
would argue that they're the two best
flyweights on the planet Bar None it's a
fair argument
um you know so this is a great fight uh
for numerous of reasons it's also when
you look at their fight it's not like
the first fight somebody dominated the
second fight somebody dominated you know
and then you're just doing a Trilogy for
the heck of it no no it's a a great
fight it's it's a tough fight for both
gentlemen you know both have uh you know
their advantages and disadvantages and
it is a straight scrap so I'm excited
for that one obviously and also just to
add more hype to it Demetrius Johnson
said this might be his last one so
hopefully it's not I I don't know if it
will be I don't know if I'm feeling that
vibe from them but we'll see
um we'll probably talk to them this week
but for DJ for to be his last fight is
insane so you've seen one of the greats
maybe walk away
um and it just happens to be the first
time one Championship breaks ground in
the United States you have Rod Tang if
you don't know Rod tank He's a fly
Flyway uh Muay Thai Guy
probably the best in the world
if you don't know who he is look him up
he will knock your freaking socks off
this guy's so talented so fun to watch
you mean uh DJ actually fought in a kind
of a super fight thing where it was a
mixed rules a mix it was a collab where
it was Muay Thai and MMA so first round
was Muay Thai obviously TJ got dealt
with in Muay Thai second round was MMA
then DJ got his neck and choked him
literally to sleep I don't think
rohitang know how to tap he's just like
what's happening here and then she went
to sleep so that was fun uh and then you
also have uh Mikey mucho Messi final
Osama
um and Mikey is the most talented
Grappler on the planet he's also the
instructor for a guy named Mark
Zuckerberg ever heard of him he talks
about all that and finding the kid
um but yeah he's the world champion he
only competes really now in one
Championship he because even on finally
can I go how's the contract work because
there's so many competitions you know
the worlds and all that stuff happening
can you go outside he's like there's no
need to I compete every month and I'm
making you know real good money so it's
changing the Jitsu game man but Mikey's
a great kid Mikey's a pizza connoisseur
he's a pizza expert so the team here was
like oh Mikey eats one state he'll eats
Pizza let's go get him Pizza yeah so up
the street from area of an erwan which
is if I don't is everyone outside of L.A
are there Airlines I don't know I've
never seen them
for those of you that I don't know
everyone knows about Whole Foods it's
like a Whole Foods on steroids you it's
a nightmare their food's delicious their
hot bar is second to none
the problem is if you just get like four
chicken tenders you can't get out of
there without spending forty dollars
like if you just get chicken tenders
it's forty dollars everything's forty
dollars minimum it's a nightmare but uh
so we you know we thought yeah it might
get the world champion he wants to go
getting pizza from that fancy place so
we order two large one pepperoni one
cheese pizza we're pretty hyped about it
some of my favorite pizza now is it
Julina takeaway no is it juice that no
is it print Street no is it bodegas no
but it's good for Calabasas it was good
we enjoyed we enjoyed it
we doing the show I'm like Mikey there's
your pizza my man we open up he goes
oh oh he's looking at oh man wasn't
piping hot looked a little stale and he
went that's not high level and I went
well because that's not you could tell
he was like stressing like that's not I
love a pizza oh yeah I mean it's good
for around here he goes yeah I go hold
on dude you don't have to eat this he
goes oh thank God I'm like oh you
thought we were forcing to eat this
snowman you choke everybody
unconsciously if you wanted to you don't
you don't have to do anything you don't
want to do my man you don't have to do
anything but he uh yeah that's a pizza I
had a slice of pepperoni myself it was
delicious it's a good pizza the crust is
good but Mikey was not feeling it man
Brian Johnson said oh [__] [__] Irwin
Pizza
but it was delicious I mean he said
that's Mikey there's so much fun thank
you for having us see you next week I'll
find this good pizza in Colorado to eat
you'll find his pizza in Colorado I'll
find his pizza in Colorado that's my
hometown
uh yeah you know I did promise him I'd
wear a shirt to the fights so I could go
order a shirt ASAP
unless they sell it at the venue I don't
know how that works such a good dude
though yeah he's such a sweet and he's
such a sweetheart such a badass too man
yep really good yeah Chachi I can rant
and Rave about Charlie for days for days
dude he's he's a he's an outlier amongst
all the you know the the faces of the
people that own all these fight
organizations or just Pro Sports in
general you know the commissioners of
all these leagues the owners of the UFC
owner of uh pfl Bellator all these
owners ain't no one Stacks up with
chocolate
when you look at the degree from Harvard
what he came from an actual mixed
martial artist Like Trains every day has
a background mixed martial arts isn't
doing this to be famous isn't doing this
to make money could have sold a long
time ago doesn't do that stuff he's
doing it for the game
his passion yeah that's what he said
straight passion he's my favorite my
absolute favorite and this is what
frustrates me
you know we shot with chatri and Mikey
on Friday and at the time we're talking
about Francis ingano and with Francis
my take on Francis right now I'm sure is
gonna be current events while jump into
it right now my and then we'll get into
UFC 288 my take on France is this the
longer that it goes on that he's not
that he doesn't have a fight coming up
the worst it is for him as far as
leverage people forget this game evolved
so fast there's other Headliners there's
other big names out there the boxing
game he he's the you know he's fun but
he's you know he's the side piece he's
not wifey he's the side piece in all of
this so the more this goes on and we
don't hear his name in the big fights in
boxing we haven't heard for a while now
Deontay Wilder teased it but then now
he's ranked number one so I don't know
what's going on there probably fighting
a big boxing name but the longest goes
on for Francis the worst it is if you're
a Francis fan it's not good
so when chatri when he came in me and
him were talking about he goes yeah I'm
supposed to meet with uh Francis in La
he's in La we've been trying to meet for
a while now finally we're making it
happen you know we we have an offer and
he's like money's not the issue we can
pay more than anybody UFC says they
offer him the highest contract ever uh
heavyweights ever in UFC will destroy
that we're offering more money than he
can imagine so money's not the issue
it's these other things outside of that
that makes it
um tough for us you know some of his
demands and it's not my it's not my
place to air chatri's details out with
the negotiation it's not what I do
but some of the demands that he told me
that Francis made blew my mind I was
like oh that's the problem there's the
there's the problem now I don't know if
I don't think martel's not his age
anymore I don't know who he's listening
to
um but it's not I'll put it this way
it's not good nobody is going to sign
him for that nobody nobody it's not
happening so at some point he needs to
get off his high horse and go I'm still
a fighter I'm still a fighter I need to
do what's best for me and now I know he
wants to do what's best for the fighters
and equal rights and all that [__] when
it comes to fighter pay all good dude
but what's gonna happen is your voice is
so much more powerful if you want to
make a change become world champion one
Championship beat Deontay Wilder and
then keep harping on this but right now
there's not a ton of Leverage there and
some of the stuff that he's asking for
I've never heard of Fighters asking for
ever in my entire life I've heard of
some crazy [__] from comics with The
Writers when it comes to green rooms for
Fighters NFL players I've heard of crazy
[__] you hear this you're like oh no
he's gonna no he's gonna take that then
chatri came out today and said met with
him uh after careful reflection we
decide not to submit our final offer
France is a good guy a good Champion I
wish him continued success and happiness
uh at the end of the day I didn't feel
France and I were fully aligned on
non-financial matters it's nothing
personal it's just a lack of alignment
that should be alarming if you're in the
Francis ingano camp
so already
outside of pay so we know it's not pay
outside of pay Francis can't go anywhere
make more money they was going to make
in one championship
so that's off the table let's take a
little break from chatting all things
fighting because UFC 288 is here this
Saturday and we have one heck of a main
event Al Jermaine Sterling versus Henry
sahudo the belt is on the line who will
secure the bantamweight title place your
bets on DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
UFC new customers can make a five dollar
bet and score 150 in bonus bets
instantly plus everyone can take an MMA
action to the next level with the
DraftKings same game parlays combine
multiple bets for a shot at even bigger
payout listen I like the dogs on this
especially if you're a betting man which
I am I like Steamroller as the dog I
like Chrome Gracie as a dog
I like uh Muhammad as the dog and aljo
aljo Jermaine Sterling as the dog as
well better parlay on those dogs you're
making bank bro download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app right now use code shop
show bet five dollars on any UFC 288 and
get 150 in bonus bets instantly this is
that's this Saturday on DraftKings
Sportsbook with the code shop show schab
show gambling problem called win Hunter
Gambler in Massachusetts call
800-327-5050 or visit gambling helpline
m a DOT org in New York call 8778 Hope
NY or text Hope NY
467-369 in Kansas call
1-800-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort Kansas 21 older and
most eligible States plus but age varies
by jurisdiction eligibility restrictions
apply C show notes for details see
draftkings.com Sportsbook for details in
state-specific responsible gambling
resources
DraftKings promo code shop show UFC 288
let's go
UFC now could be uh negotiated
negotiation tactic from Dane white goes
we'll never sign him back so let's
assume Dana's true to his word you'll
seize off the table
so you have one championship in UFC the
two biggest by far in all of the world
nobody bigger what's left Bellator
probably can't afford him uh we pfl okay
beer knuckle can't afford them they
already said uh we can't meet those
demands so he very pissed off the UFC
which is the biggest player in the game
of North America you've already
scorched the Earth as far as
negotiations go with one Championship
now what
now you have to pray to God that the
boxing route works out and boy if you
think MMA is a tough business there is
not a more corrupt business in this
[__] professional sports world than
boxing and that's what you're putting
all your backs eggs in your basket it's
insane it's it's such a shame I don't
know who's helping them negotiate I
don't know if he has an agent almost as
a Lamar Jackson thing we don't want to
pay an agent percentage that is not the
way to do it
it's not the way to do it
because one championship and this is why
it made so much sense one Championship
goes
we believe in mixed martial arts we
believe in martial arts in general so
Francis will have an opportunity to a
fight for World Championship in mixed
martial arts and B we're open to him
fighting boxing when he box first that
was his caveat with UFC well I want to
box first and then fighting you see and
you'll see when absolutely not gonna
fight John then we'll figure out the box
and Fran said nope I want a box first
when Championship say cool we'll let you
do that we'll be part of that we'll be
part of the marking of that we'll do all
that for you
now what's he gonna do
it's not good man it's not good and I
don't know who needs to get in Frontier
nobody needs you
big martial arts across the board box
and cross board will be just fine
nobody's bigger than the game nobody
nobody the closest person we've ever had
that was bigger than the game is Conor
McGregor
he has some a little more leverage in
Francis right so for France it's like I
don't know who you're listening to man
but this is not going well this has been
a [__] disaster
the one I thought this was the perfect
situation it's so frustrating man so
frustrating and that one championship
fight that heavyweight fight is that
Russian not a walk in the park
but they're you're allowed to do that
and box
where are you gonna go
you start your own League
you know what I'm saying what the [__]
you gonna do man it's so frustrating
that would be the dude Antoni and
Tally's a problem he's a [__] problem
he's undersized at 223 should probably
be a light heavier in most areas but I
think the perfect weight for a
heavyweight's about 235 240. you'll get
Kane in this Prime like steep anus Prime
JDS in his prime
so I remember looking at uh the Articles
we brought up before but so Bellator
said they were
50 50. that's how hard the negotiations
were and then uh pfl said like we're
heading in a positive direction but
we're not sure what's going so he had he
must have some crazy demands I mean it
seems like he has some crazy demands I
know for a fact yeah yeah no I know
because that's every single from the
whole promotion that's every promotion
and they would love to have them then
yeah think about they're like oh think
about one chatri think about chatra he's
offering the monsters and he was willing
to meet with him in Dubai he was willing
to fly to [__] Morocco he's fly to
Africa just to figure this deal out
finally they meet in LA and he goes the
money you're asking for here you go the
boxing here you go
the other demands the other demands is
what they're so outrageous that Chachi
goes we're good we're just going to
carry on we're good it's it God you
[__] up
it's never been a perfect relationship
I'm so frustrated because I'm a Francis
fan
and I remember Markel like he's a friend
of the show obviously I love Marco he
was he had his back with the whole UFC
stuff he actually had a fight with or
online fight with Dana White but then
suddenly he's gone from the picture now
too like think about what Marcel did
just for his career like think about
[__] Markel got think about that
text that got leaked about the racism
that he was dealing with too with UFC
brass Dana think about all that stuff
right and Markel just got trashed his
name got dragged through the mud but he
knew he's doing the right thing and then
they're finally at the end of the tunnel
France goes Thanksgiving through the
tunnel see ya
being frustrated for Markel
because this your payoff was going to be
this
if he had the right guy on his team
they'd go whoa France is Francis Francis
we know you want to change the game all
that stuff let's handle our job first
and then do that and then worry about
that stuff you have a much bigger
platform much more leverage once you're
world champion over here once you have
whatever it is 50 mil in the bank from
fighting Deontay Wilder Fury then let's
talk about this but right now you got a
lot of work to do dude we got a lot of
work you're you're focused on the wrong
[__] man and you're not young he's not
that young you know
it's so frustrating I can't stand this
now it's also on the side too uh 36 you
know
with you know coming off a knee injury
so you know there's that and there's
also what's frustrating and again I'm a
guy when uh NFL if you're an NFL fan the
Lamar Jackson stuff is very I mean
everyone's covered it so he decided not
to hire an agent and have his mom
represent him to save the three to five
percent on the contract
again it sounds good that you're saving
three to five percent and he got paid
the highest I think of any uh Court he's
not the highest paid quarterback with
the guaranteed money
it's a lot of money
but would you rather have 500 million
and give someone five percent or have
300 million and you keep it all you know
so when there's agents exist for a
reason you know now a lot of them are
dinosaurs and you know sometimes you
don't need them or man you may not need
when it comes an agent the reason you
need them is they can start these
bidding wars for your career so for
Lamar Jackson his mom doesn't know the
GMS at all the teams and create
different bids and see test the waters
to see where you're at now he got the
money right they were at the last second
you got the money so it worked out for
them technically I will be
willing to argue that he probably would
have got paid even more if he had a
legit agent on his side with Francis
okay dude don't use an agent negotiate
yourself with a guy like cha tree who's
Harvard educated
are you a guy like Dana White who's been
in there with the big boys he's a shark
and his lawyers the best of the best try
to try to argue with those guys
that's that they might as well jump in
the octagon and fight they shouldn't be
fighting he shouldn't be negotiating
and he's learned the the worst way man
it could cause him his career he's
learning the worst way it's a it's a
shame man I'm so frustrated so
frustrated
there are outliers all right like still
Sean O'Malley I guess remember he says
he does his own negotiating so he's
maybe the kind of personality that can
do that and I
again he doesn't have a degree in
business and I'm all the power to him
because apparently his contract's a lot
of money
but when he becomes Champion if he does
God willing becomes champion and you get
in those pay-per-view points
what experiences he have to negotiate
those pay-per-view points that's where
you get [__] you money so an agents can
go well I represent Anderson Silva Brock
Lesnar Conor McGregor we know what those
guys got so we can negotiate that if you
have no clue you think you're getting a
good deal I'm sure sugar Sean thought or
thinks he got the good deal I'd be
wanting to imagine if you had an agent
even though you're giving five percent
ten percent is he probably would have
got you a better deal so we think it's
going well but I would be in my
experience in all these years I would be
willing to bet the agent probably could
have gotten more money
you know because they know the ins and
outs they're dealing with this all the
time you don't want to be the guy deal
for Francis you don't want to be you
want to be training you're going to be
thinking about beating Deontay Wilder
[__] Tyson Fury it's hard enough but
okay you're a businessman now yeah now
you want to be a businessman now's not
the time yeah now you want to deal with
this and go through all this trials and
tribulation learn the hard way you're
you're getting an education now you know
it's not good
regardless one Championship that whole
uh rant about uh one Championship is
they have a great card this weekend and
I'll be there I will be there cage side
of my uh Mikey shirt on uh just
screaming like a real
uh real uh cage groupie just a real rat
group I think they're called cage rats
yeah I'll be a little cage I'm gonna
have my tits out my balls to the side uh
so you got Demetrius Johnson Mariah's uh
rubber match Rod Tang the best striker
in the world
she the pizza kind of Sword Pizza expert
the most technical Jutsu player on the
planet you'll stamp fair tax you have
Roberto Sol ditch who is the freaking
RoboCop creation and after you're done
listening this make sure you listen fire
kid because Chachi tells a story about
sign him in Croatia and they go to Crow
cop's house and eat with them and train
with them and it's fantastic he talks
about how big of a star he is you have
Sage Northcutt coming back after all
these years what five years I think it's
like three or four three or four
um and then one of also one of my
favorite Fighters uh in the world you
have RDR
um just the The Savage The Savage and
that's us that's grappling all right
against the one of the rotoler brothers
Thai yes they're badass super badass
so you have that going on you got UFC
288 let's jump in the UFC 288
so UFC 288 I do think it's worth your
money I think we're spoiled because you
know the the papers have been so great
the fight nights have been rough this
past weekend's how dare you UFC and
that's now shade on any of the fighters
on the card it's just you know they're
they're they're they're getting one over
on us they they have to meet those ESPN
demands and they're doing the Apec
Center which sucks for the fighters
there's no fans The Experience sucks as
viewers too the whole thing's [__]
but uh you know this card is quality you
know again I would pay just for aljo
Henry sudo Muhammad Gilbert Burns Chrome
Gracie Charles uh Jordan Bryce Mitchell
um Drew Dober Matt uh Steamroller I'd
pay just to see them take my money all
right I'm in that's on the guardian
screwd over take my money I don't even
need to know the rest of the card
it can be an all-female card and just
have them as the co-main event I'm in
take my money you know so
um I think people are a little too harsh
on this card because we're spoiled but
uh it's a good card
uh with Drew Dober Matt uh Steamroller
ferolla you know this is one of those
fights where Drew job was number 14 uh
he's won three in a row he does training
with my old team at high altitude
martial arts so I have a sweet spot for
Drew Dover he also came up same
uh
kind of local circuit I did in ring of
fire so that I love Drew dobre so my
favorite Fighters I always root for Drew
Dober except when he fights Matt and
that's my guy I like Matt we have Matt
on the show uh today and Matt is just uh
you can't help but love the guy he's a
ray Longo met Sierra uh Protege he
trains with Al Joe he's just a quality
[__] human being and he's an exciting
fighter man he just has to fight smart
against Drew Dover you can't do the
Bobby green [__] and hands down and play
that phone booth you know technique and
you can get knocked out Drew Dober is a
[__] bazooka so
um I'm taking mad on this if you fight
smart I'm taking my boy Matt then I told
him if he wins we get him on a fight
campaign and food truck if you lose
we'll see right we'll just get her we'll
do Matt
um and then Chrome Gracie never mad when
he fights this is this fight could be in
1993. you have a straight Jitsu Guy
versus straight Striker it's and now
Charles is coming off two losses so you
know I'm sure his morale and uh I'd like
to see his mindset come in this fight
he's gonna have two losses you know
um you better watch his p's and q's you
know Crohn's one of the best I've ever
seen as far as grappling goes I grappled
him for a long time uh he's one of my
favorite human beings on Earth he's a
straight Savage his family is
responsible for mixed martial arts in
North America and across the world uh
his last fight was in 2019 against Cub
Swanson that was too much too soon that
was a bad bad matchup for him he took
some time off I'm not Madam for that it
was still fighting tonight he still gave
Cub Swanson all he could handle I didn't
it was too much too soon man the Cubs
Watson what are we doing dude
he he fought one time in the UFC and
then I kissed cop Swanson Jesus Christ
do that what's remember Korean Superboy
was killing it and they gave him come
spots and yeah dude it's [__] up like
Jesus Christ help him out here comes
with my favorites man he's got Chrome
kicking the card off taking Crown via
submission nothing new there I'm taking
Matt via TKO Chrome uh submission
this next fight Bryce flattered flat
earther Mitchell uh versus
he's a beast but he's a decision Beast
right so
when it comes to they're kind of it's a
rough matchup for Bryce Mitchell you can
tell the UFC's not flat earthers um now
he wasn't originally supposed to fight
him so it's not like they're throwing
him to the Wolves but as far as stylist
sticky it's a rough matchup for Bryce
I'm rooting for Bryce very tough night
in the office for him yeah I would
assume he's an honor dog is he
let's look
oh he's a favorite damn
oh no no no no no I saw Bryce here yeah
you highlighted Bryce on my damn Bryce
is my name
uh yeah Bryce is plus 221 very tough
fight for him very very tough fight
Crone's an underdog uh Matson dog oh
your boy can make some money on this
Muhammad oh sh Nikes and then tejudo
minus 105. boy there's a parlay that
gets my dick wet
that is a nice little brother is minus
105 and so here's minus 115. yeah that
means they don't know what the hell's
going on they don't know so it's
basically even money but either way
um so who knows a slight favorite in
this now Drew Dober is a big favorite
minus 200 is kind of big in MMA
ah man I like the dogs here you know I
like me some dogs
go back to the lineup uh Bryce tough
night in the office I hope Bryce gets it
done I like I love Bryce here's my thing
too
Bryce Mitchell
um uh Kobe Covington these you know
Kobe's clearly a trump guy or pretends
he's a trump guy so he gets a lot of
hate Bryce Mitchell flat Earth so he
gets a lot of hate
I can separate Bryce being a flat
earther and whatever crazy conspiracy
she's on it's fun to me that's his thing
I can separate that from the human from
the fighter and still light you know you
can still like them you know if your
favorite fighter for whatever reason is
a a DeSantis guy or a biting guy you
know you can still root for him
just because he's either left or right
or in the middle you know or he's a flat
Earth or his conspiracy guy you know he
can still root for the gut just because
he's in a line with you politically or
with conspiracies you can still like the
guy it's okay it doesn't make him a bad
person just makes him wrong right
so uh I'm rooting for Bryce I like Bryce
but it's a great guy he's a fun
interview good dude too man he's just
flat Earth today Super Flat Earth he
started talking to Elon Musk man you
ain't never been to Mars like holy [__]
talking [__] to Elon Musk do you listen
to your thing he said Joe Rogan I want
to debate you're like oh my God you have
a better chance winning this fight than
beating Joe Rogan in debate man that's a
bad idea but I love Bryce yeah he's
absolutely love Bryce oh yeah just on
drugs uh she's a is she a dog in this
again I think the last fight was tough
man
oh no she's a fit oh yeah she's a
favorite slight favorite minus 170. okay
yeah they had to put some money on yawn
especially after that last fight yeah
John is badass too hell yeah
uh then the co-main event
outside of Steamroller and Drew Dover is
my favorite matchup on the card uh our
boy Bilal Muhammad versus Gilbert Burns
uh both food truck alumni I hate picking
against either one of these guys but
um mohammed's a plus 110. I like the
dogs here listen when this fight got
announced shortly like a week ago uh you
know Muhammad coming off
um you know his his fight over Sean
Brady the the hardcore fan base wants to
him get a title shot this is a whoever
wins this guaranteed gets a title shot
now you're not gonna fight next and I
talked to Muhammad about that you have
to wait which is worth it you know he's
been doing it long enough but this is
gonna be a title Contender fight so
whoever wins I would almost guarantee
gets a title shot next after Kobe and
Leon fight
um you know we've seen Gilbert take his
his run at the the title shot didn't
work out for him again even though it
was Kamara Usman
um he had the the loss against Hamza
which actually I think did even if even
though he lost that fight still did more
Foursquare than than almost anything
because hamzas is complete Savage
nightmare he went toe-to-toe with him
fight of the night ridiculous fight you
know so
um
you know against Neil magni uh Gilbert
this thing against Jorge I
I'm not as high on Gilbert after the
Jorge fight as most people are I didn't
think that was a great performance
um Jorge did a good job executing his
his Jiu Jitsu defense there you know uh
Gilbert did say he was greased in for a
reason
what you don't want to have happen is
below season goes oh he's not that
dangerous on the ground because you're
gonna find out the hard way and probably
lose that fight Gilbert is an outlier on
the ground when it comes that I think
Muhammad needs to do the same gameplay
Sean Brady avoid the ground turn into
kickboxing match
um I would say Blah's more verse more
versatile on the feet but when it comes
to power Gilbert definitely has the
advantage comes to power avoid the big
shot
I would assume his fico's the decision
avoid the big shot it's five rounds void
the big shot be methodical just get
rounds in the bank and I think uh
Mohammed wins via decision I think it's
the next title shot for Al Jermaine uh
Henry sahudo this one's tough there's
reason the odds are like this right
minus uh 105 to minus 115 so the the odd
makers don't know what to expect when it
comes to Henry sahulu he's been out
three years so you can base off the
domic cruise fight but three years
especially at that weight class is a
long freaking time now how do you say
Judo is not one of those guys that's
just been fishing and hanging out at the
beach and doing the [__] he's he's
active you know he's he's helped Jon
Jones out he's trained with Mighty Mouse
uh he dreams with sugar Shawn he trains
with all these guys he helps them out
game plans when Corner guys he trains
with them so he's been super active so
you're dealing with a different type of
human being here he's also an outlier
when it comes to his mindset there's a
reason he was a double UFC champion
um you know and he was also Olympic gold
Champion so his mindset is what
separates them from everybody else on
this UFC roster but I I do not like when
guys take three years off I don't care
what your mindset is
I also don't like you're fighting again
as Prime and aljo where ring Russ is
going to be a factor here
um you just hope that
if you are a Hennessy huto fan that he
doesn't get finished before he can make
those changes to kind of win some rounds
there because aljo is a finisher so
um I do think it's a very tough fight
for Henry sehudo at his age if you look
at the odds odds are not on his side at
his age and going for a title shot
um I will I would probably put my money
in aljo on this I'll probably take aljo
I'll give you my picks right now I'll
take let me see it chin
uh I'm taking the dogs here now listen
I'm taking the dogs if I wanted to be on
the side of caution make sure I'm right
so you guys you know take my my pick
serious I can do that that's what every
other show you watch is gonna do that's
not what I do I I if you want to make
money I like Steamroller as a underdog I
like Chrome Gracie
um I would probably lay off the Bryce
Mitchell one just because stylistically
the chance of him get a knock or
something like that's not good
um I would take Muhammad as a dog and
I'll take Al Joe
those are all dogs I'm taking all dogs
here so I'm taking Matt crone
um Muhammad and aljo
those are my picks
great card though one Championship great
card taking DJ in that main event now
I'm taking Mikey no I'm taking Soul
ditch you know what I'm saying yeah you
know I'm taking Stanford yep
but either way great cards coming up
it's gonna be a fun weekend I will be
out there for one Championship with
wifey it's her birthday too Cinco de
Mayo a lot going on is her birthday
really on Cinco de Mayo yeah dude that's
Mexican as it gets so Mexican
and cadella always fights on Cinco de
Mayo so you watch that [__] he's
like a minus three thousand favorite
thanks for that dude
that's boxing damn on the undercard this
dude uh janabeck is minus six thousand
why fight
money yeah true all right let's take a
little break for we jump right back into
the fisticuffs got a busy weekend one
Championship UFC 288 a lot is going down
but I will be doing a live Cowboys fight
campaign with Ryan Garcia George Janko
another very special guest this Saturday
at 7 p.m Pacific live on thick boy
YouTube and you know one thing for sure
I will be all up on my happy hippo
because when I'm doing podcasting I'm
doing stand-up I'm just working out I'm
using the best cradle on planet Earth
it's from Happy Hippo happyhippo.com
promo code thick 23 thick with three C's
get you 20 off the best Kratom on the
planet Bar None they got it all they got
gummies they got the instant shots which
I use for every show I always have it in
my case when I'm traveling I just pop
those before I hit the stage pop those
before I walked in this studio because I
love Kratom but I only trust one Kratom
company and that's Happy Hippo I
specifically reached out to them said
hey love the product would like to get
you on the shows and that's how this
came to fruition here we are happy hippo
the only Kratom that I trust whatever
you need they got powders they got
gummies they got the instant shots they
got it all all right that's Happy
hippo.com promo code is thick 23 with
three C's you save 20 off you can use
that code as many times as you want if
you want to try Kratom but you're
worried about what's in it or you're
worried about if it's actual Kratom what
kind of if there are other additives in
it you need happy hippo that's why I
trust them the only company I trust
happyhippo.com promo code thick23 oh boy
way for you health nuts out there guess
what it's that time of year no it's not
Black Friday but it is on its freaking
semi-annual sale and it's happening
right now you get the lowest price of
some of on its most popular products for
a limited time only you can get 25 off
usually I'll only give you guys 10 off
but this semi-annual sale on its running
right now it's gonna be very short you
get 25 off Alpha Brain ten percent off
kettlebells 60 off other door buster
deals that's insane don't wait too long
because the sale ends May 14th so you
have two weeks that means you only have
two weeks to take advantage of these
amazing deals the honor to provide too
it's not Black Friday it's on its
semi-annual sale right now so what are
you waiting for head to audit.com all
right if you head to audit.com right now
you get 25 off Alpha Brain temps off
kettlebells 60 off all other fun stuff
all right don't miss out on this
incredible sale it's only two weeks
through May 14th on it.com to join their
semi annual wholesale right now we are
live with the shirtless wonder the most
powerful redhead in the UFC hands down
it is the steamroller himself Matt
ferrola what's going on brother
yeah not much man just entering fight
week you know shirtless feeling good
dude I I would never wear a shirt if I
had that body man the only the only
person you're competing with in Combat
Sports as far as the most powerful
redhead is uh Canelo
and all right I've heard that a lot
really you're more handsome than he is
and you're bigger you're seeing Canelo
he's not a big dude
no I've never seen him but oh seen him
in person but uh you know I'm trying to
get my hands like him so I'll take it
you could beat him in a street fight
they'll tell you that right now dude
boxing you know I love you but that's a
different story let's not get carried
away here MMA destroy him there you go
I'll take that how you how you feeling
for a fight week man how's the cut down
to 55 for you is it has it been a beast
this time or what's going on here
dude I'm feeling great man I like I
crushed a workout this morning and then
I just jumped in the cold plunge it's
like I live right on the water in Long
Island so I just jumped in the water for
10 minutes slight Flex yeah man I got
that that salt water healing I got that
cold water love it dude yeah man my
weight's on point I'm so hungry right
now I'm hungry physically I'm hungry
mentally I'm ready to eat this dude's
face yeah it's quite the match-up I I'll
tell you what man like I said I was a
fan before he came on but I've been
harping I I don't know why this isn't on
the main card like it's you look at the
card you know and I'm not bagging on the
card and you know I fought where you
guys are fighting in New Jersey there
usually they bring the power it's like
you're the main event common event fire
your fight fire I just I can't believe
it's not in the main card like looking
at it for like fights of the night it's
and I know why they're doing it right
because you guys are the main main event
on the prelims they want to get people
to see that and they're all right we got
to get more we gotta be by the
pay-per-view so it's kind of a tip of
the hat to you but I just this is has
main card written all over it man it's
such a good fight
yeah yeah I guess I I guess I get why
they're doing it you know they want to
put that exciting fight on the last
fight on the prelims
um and then I guess they they're pushing
that Gracie you know they got Crown
Gracie he's got that Gracie name
um so I think they're just pushing that
but you know I don't mind I'll be
fighting right around like 9 30 so I
like that time and uh you know the only
the only bad part about not being on the
main card was like I was looking forward
to doing like a press conference and you
know get you know dressed up and doing
next I've never done that
well you will my man you win this one
and that's kind of how it goes you know
where I I was the the main event on the
prelims when I fought Levar Johnson and
then once once they see that you pass
that test and then it's just your Mr
pay-per-view from there on out and
especially this magnitude of a fight
against Drew Dober you know was he
ranked 14th so it's uh the first time
you're fighting you know Big Time rank
guy like this he's a knockout artist
you're a knockouter especially last two
but you can kind of do it all so it's
just the perfect matchup to get you on
that Big Time pay-per-view card
yeah man I love the match up you know
well I've been watching Dover you know
forever and then uh you know getting
this matchup I give him a lot of props
you know a lot of these high-ranked guys
don't want to really fight back but uh
you know he accepted the fight and I'm
you know I respect him for that but I'm
gonna make him pay for that
yeah I agree you know him having you
know a number next to his name a lot of
guys will use that to kind of as
leverage like no I'm not gonna fight
Steamroller like he's a he's a monster
and he's not even ranked it it doesn't
move me forward but
um you know the the ranking system and
all that I I tend not to harp on it too
much because it's all you know it's
crazy that you know Drew dover's not
ranked higher I think you should be in
the top 15 there's a bunch of other
names I can use as well so you know guys
will use that as kind of a leverage to
not fight guys like you are coming up
you know with surgeons but I do think
Drew Dober I've known Drew for a hot
second he trains with my team in Denver
at high altitude so you know Drew's been
doing what since 2009 he's old school
man he's an old school cat you know so
this fight is just so fun man I can't
wait for it
I know man like he he really is he's got
like 20 fights in the UFC uh and you
know re-watching all his fights he's got
one of the best like highlight reels of
Knockouts like I've ever seen so it just
it excites me man this fight I I got
into this to really you know fight the
best fighters in the world to test
myself against the best guys in the
world and uh you know after my last two
fights I was telling him I want a big
fight I want a big fight and uh and we
got it so I'm pumped and what does uh
what did Ray Longo admit Sierra say to
you about this when this fight got
announced what do they tell you because
you you don't get me wrong you got power
in your hands brother you got you know a
gift from God so does Drew Dober this is
one of those fights it's like all right
man you know you you want to put on a
show but you also want to fight smart
and get the W yeah Ray Longo points at
his head and he goes we're not going
psycho in there
he's right man that's what he does and I
say yes coach what what uh what coach
Longo says I do so he wants me to use my
head and fight smart you know that's
what we're gonna do smart man and do you
feel any pressure kind of you know
you're it's a big night for your camp
for the ray Longo Camp because you got
aljo as the main event so you're kind of
kicking it off you know it's fun as to
as a team to be on a UFC card and I've
been there man but there's I remember I
was the young buck and it was like oh
I'm kicking it off like you want to set
the tone for the team so the other guys
you know like yeah we are doing
something right here it's brutal when
you lose and you got to come back to the
locker like good luck man you know it's
it's a bummer dude but you feel any
pressure kicking it off for the team
not really no I mean it's a fight's a
fight you know
and uh no I'm ready man I put the work
in you know my weight's good my body's
good you know this is really the most
sparring I've done for a camp you know
so I've been sparring like three times a
week sometimes and that's because I've
been so healthy and um you know coach
Longo wants me to want to meet a box
more so I've been doing a lot of boxes
um I've been uh you know throwing the
headgear on and doing you know big glove
uh MMA rounds and then I've been putting
the little gloves on and doing more flow
rounds uh so you know I'm healthy I'm
ready I've been building my awareness
and uh you know I'm ready and when you
say a lot of boxing sparring is uh is
the camp is Ray bringing in actual
boxers or using MMA guys to mimic Dover
what are you doing there
um you know we we have so many good guys
in the gym and a lot of them come from a
boxing background
um and we're just we already have so
many good uh southpaws you know I've
been boxing with uh you know Dennis
bazooka who's an Albanian Beast
um you know kid marvelous comes uh
Justin montavo is a Bellator guy he's uh
comes from a boxing background images
man and then uh nazim sadikov I've been
sparring with he's another UFC stud and
you know all southpaws too so I'm
prepared for this guy love it man and
how do you see uh aljo and Henry sahuto
going down I mean obviously you're gonna
be a little biased but looking at it try
not to be too biased but I'm I'm algae
was my guy you know I love aljo and I do
think the layoff three years for him is
going to be a bit of a challenge for him
how do you see it going down because you
see aljo all the time yeah yeah it's
it's unbelievable the the amount of like
disrespect aljo still gets isn't it
crazy maybe not I like don't get it man
um but he's so good like just watching
him train and uh and you know being able
to train with him and like you know roll
with him and do Jitsu and and drill with
him uh he's on another level you know
he's he's the bat he's the bantamweight
goat and he's gonna prove that uh to the
world you know this Saturday
um but I I think you know his striking
is so unorthodox I think that he keeps
the range so well with his kicks and um
you know with his Combos and I think
that's gonna frustrate him I don't think
so who does ever fought anyone as big
and strong and and fast as aljo and I
think you know keeping him at range with
some good movement and good kicks and
keeping on him on the end of this punch
is going to frustrate sahuto and then
sahuto is going to go to his instincts
and try to wrestle and then that's gonna
go right into aljo's game you know
anybody who wants to Grapple with aljo
I I feel pretty confident that aljo's
gonna I call it he's got Anaconda arms
yeah
in his arms they're they're like skinny
but they're so strong yeah I can see it
enough to like snake around your neck
and then they just get so strong and
then you and then you're you're tapping
it's it's unreal so I that's how I see
the fight gone yeah and I I think the
the issue too with aljo and it's not his
fault it's kind of this perfect storm
right like with the the hate and the the
lack of respect he gets because with the
Peter yawn fights like oh he punked out
and they never thought he was the real
champ it's like well he can't control he
has nothing to do with that like what do
you want the guy to do then you look at
the the you know his other fights and
you have to give the guy credit man you
have to and this is the problem with
people disrespecting aljo even if he
were to beat Henry cejudo who's you know
arguably pound for pound top three of
all time when you look at his accolades
and he's just a monster The Narrative is
still going to be unfortunate for aljo
is uh Henry sudo's older now okay no no
yeah I don't know what it's going to
take at some point people have to go oh
no aljo's amazing you and you guys are
wasting your time disrespecting them and
you're missing it you're missing out on
one one of the rarest talents we've ever
seen in the UFC you [__] morons
yeah you know that's it though you know
they've been counting us out from day
one you know counting out Matt Sarah
against GSP counting out Chris Weidman
against Anderson Silva count out Al Joe
Peter Young you know they're counting me
out against Drew Dober and Watson saw
were a strong island guys we we prove
him wrong and uh you know we're some
tough tough guys over here and I can't
wait to go out there and show it yeah I
can't wait man and with uh how do you
feel about with marab and the aljo stuff
you guys talk about that because as a
fighter you have to understand
you know you know how it is like if you
were able to you know God willing you
you get your title shot and you're able
to fight for a title that's
life-changing for you and your family
you're married right
yeah yeah so for you know you have your
wife and you know once you have kids and
all that stuff like that fight changed
your life changes the course of your
life being a UFC champion will literally
change your life overnight
so there's there's not a person on this
Earth besides my brother that I wouldn't
fight inside that octagon to achieve UFC
Championship status so when I hear him
Rob say that apartment is like I get it
and I love how close you guys are but at
the end of the day man the goal why you
signed up to fight in UFC why marab why
Al Joe whoever it is the reason he went
to the UFC to become UFC world champion
you know so that that I get why he's
doing it and I have a ton of respect for
it and I'm sure as a team you guys have
talked about it but when it comes to
that that's the one caveat I'm like uh
if it's four title shot man you it it
there's no friends at that point there's
no friends in the game how do you guys
feel about it
yeah I mean these guys fight every day
in the gym every day and um then they're
not going to fight each other you know
they're Brothers we're all Brothers
um and I think there there's ways that
both of their careers can go you know
forward positively without them fighting
each other and I just wish you know the
UFC and the people could get behind that
and you got to take it one fight at a
time you know because Anything could
happen anything could happen I think you
know Al Joe's got his fight with sahudo
you know Rob should be you know fighting
San Hagen next I don't see why they
don't make that fight
um and then and then you know after that
fight you reassess and you see where
everyone's at you know I think Al Joe is
definitely eventually going to go up
away class you know to finish
um I think you know aljo beats the Hutto
beats Somali and then probably goes up
and then murab you know he could beat
sanagan and then uh and then maybe fight
for the vacant title after that but you
know you really got to take it one fight
at the fight at a time and um you know
both of both of them are on on good uh
good positive uh uh you know moving
forward
I wish everyone would get behind that
and you know there's things bigger than
fighter bigger than bigger than fighter
bigger fighting bigger than money and uh
you know that's the relationships we
build through this and um you know
that's you can't buy that with money
yeah I like that perspective I I just
hope like you said I hope everybody else
could jump on that kind of perspective
of there's bigger things than just
fighting and become world champion
because the UFC if they want that and
Rob turns it down a few times it can get
dicey for him but unfortunately for him
he's so talented there's not a lot of
things you can do as far as match-up
wise to discipline them there's just not
I don't with his wrestling background
his cardio and you know his tenacity and
speed and quickness okay okay who's
gonna talk to me then and try to you
know punish me good luck you know and he
just you guys just keep winning and that
stuff takes care of itself
yeah Rob's like a cheat code it's like
it doesn't make sense how he doesn't get
tired he'll just he'll just Spar like
you know rounds at the round and
somebody will walk in the gym and won
The Spar and you're like yeah I'm ready
and he just keeps going I just get freak
huh
yeah yeah machine mentality that's uh I
mean for him to shoot 49 takedown
attempts against Peter's
I watched that fight the next day I was
sparring and I'm like all right I'm
gonna try to shoot as much as I can
during this sparring inside and I
thought maybe like five times and was
dog [__] tired yeah bro different level
man and I'm sure for you like with you
with training with those guys with Al
Joe marab all these other Savages you
have at Ray Longo's gym there uh your
wrestling has to be getting pretty
freaking good man
yeah you know my wrestling my Jiu Jitsu
my striking uh that's why I love mixed
martial arts there's so many you know
aspects to the fight game
um and and I love you know focusing on
each one of them but then what I really
love is is how you know you blend it all
together in the cage you know to to beat
a specific opponent well don't forget
you said that when you fight on Saturday
because listen I love my I love myself a
real slobber knocker with Drew Doberman
let's use all the tools there if we can
bro you know what I'm saying that we're
using our head we're not going psycho in
there we're using our yeah don't do it
brother don't do it I feel like and
correct me if I'm wrong I feel like the
winner of this fight there's a lot to it
because that'd be four in a row for Drew
Dober three for you and you beat a
ranked opponent you get put in the top
15 but also both of you drew Dober and
yourself have been calling out Patty
pimlet for quite some time I feel like
the winner of this probably fights Patty
pimlet
yeah definitely I mean once I once I uh
handle Dober
um I'm gonna I'm gonna beat up Patty
it's only a matter of time and now
you're a WWE Fan
I would assume you get on that mic and
give us one hell of a promo with your
WWE knowledge and call out Patty and
that's probably gonna be the talk of UFC
288.
yeah yeah that sounds about right you
know I just gotta you know I like a lot
of people ask me they're like how do you
like prepare what you're gonna say after
the fight no no I don't like yeah like
I'm so dialed in like I'm focused on the
fight focus on Dober
um and then you know after that I I'll
you know I'll be I'll be on my a game
and uh and then we we move on to uh to
serve in Patty pimlet some Humble Pie
yeah that's the move man you don't want
to you definitely don't overlook Drew
Dober I would actually uh and I would
assume most people would agree Drew
Dober is a more dangerous fight for you
than Patty pimlet you know
yeah yeah oh definitely yes yeah Drew's
such a Savage
um and how how are things in uh Strong
Island Man
uh it's going good you know it's
starting to get nice out here you know
there's nothing better than summer time
on Long Island
um so you know they would love to come
out there man
yeah man you need to uh so yeah I'm
looking forward to uh you know getting
this big win and then uh staying in
shape all summer you know I'm feeling
good you know I'm looking good I don't
want to become the cream roller for the
summer time hell no give me the tan
roller brother the tan I don't know how
you do in the sun usually redheads don't
do great in the Sun but I do good man
well I gotta go through a lobster phase
I go through my Lobster face and then it
turns into a nice bronze oh dude I'm
excited for that almost too excited uh
and how do you how are you feeling you
had some recent comments about uh
Chandler and uh Connor what's your
thoughts on uh Chandler and condo hey do
you think the fight's gonna happen B do
you think they can kind of save this
Ultimate Fighter kind of free fall it's
been on man nobody's paying attention to
it I assume that's the reason why they
have Conor on so people remember that
Ultimate Fighter used to be the biggest
show in the world so how you feeling
about it I'm excited for it I mean who
doesn't want to watch uh you know Conor
McGregor on on his on his proper 12
whiskey I heard he was just drunk all
the whole season and
it just just getting wasted and uh you
know on all the testosterone probably
possible
um yeah I think it's gonna be
entertaining an entertaining show and
I'm excited for it but we'll see what
the you know it's pretty crazy how he
was allowed you know to to Really juice
to you know let his his leg heal yeah
but you know I'm I'm not mad at it like
I I get it you know now I just don't
think like if you just look at the way
the UFC Works unless they give him some
exemption which people would freak the
hell out about I just don't see him
fighting this year
you know with the six months of testing
I don't know if he's even entered the
protocol testing time so it's like
if you just look at it the way it
usually works and now it is Conor
McGregor so they can make exceptions but
it's like hey does anybody else realize
how this sport Works he's probably not
fighting this year
yeah we'll see and then you seem like
that bare knuckle is just still swigging
his whiskey yeah I know dude dude I I
need to take a page out of his book as
far as marketing man and just start
swinging tiger thick you know but he
does well with it did you see I I think
what happened too is he was drinking you
know he doesn't want to do bare knuckle
what are we talking about here anybody's
drinking then the just the sheer demand
of like the peer pressure fans like get
in there and he gets in Mike Perry's
face somebody woke up uh the next
morning kind of hung over like oh my god
what the hell was that I bet Dana was
like what the [__] are you doing dude
what are you doing oh it was great
though who uh that that was a Face-Off
that I definitely love to see you know
who I love Mike Perry man I I go watch
that dude fight every weekend and that
dude was born for Bare knuckle dude he
was the hero that nobody knew we needed
especially when it comes to Bare knuckle
because in the UFC we liked them like
the UFC fan base liked him he was put on
exciting fights and was always such a
dog and we love them you know and they
had some altercation outside the Octagon
then lost a few and then goes away and
you think that's it and then bare
knuckle comes and I bet even bare
Knuckles like yeah we'll sign them they
didn't know he's gonna be the face of
the organization like he's when I think
of bare knuckle he's the guy now like
he's the guy and look Michael Venom page
Luke rockhold dude it's nuts it's like
he's the guy
yeah he is man like I said he was born
for Bare knuckle boxing and I'm glad he
found it and I'm always rooting for him
so and that Face-Off of McGregor was was
awesome so but we'll see you know
McGregor's definitely got his uh hands
full with Chandler Chandler's no
pushover no but I I think I think Connor
just does so well against guys he has
reach on like I agree
it's just got like you know the Mendez
fight and and I think he'll probably
handle in the same way but we'll see
maybe maybe putting on all that muscle
is is changed you know changed the way
he fights a little bit so I mean I'm I'm
interested to see yeah I also I get
worried when guys are aren't active you
know when guys aren't that active in
actually competing I always get a little
worried because we don't know what
version we're gonna get the counter we
got in the Dustin Poirier fight wasn't a
bad Connor when he broke his leg you
know it's a tragedy but you know so he
wasn't bad in that but we didn't see a
ton you know but he looked pretty good
in that whenever a guy's a long left
like even with Henry sahuto and I'm a
betting man but if you look at the odds
of a guy over the age of I think uh 32
or something like that and who in title
fights they're like 60 and one like it
doesn't go well for people that are
older ever ever and then that's not
including the three-year layoff so we
know that aljo is firing all cylinders
it's the best version of aljo we've ever
seen with Henry cejudo you got to go
back three years we fought you know at
Dominic Cruz and we're you know you
gotta hope he's we know he's been in the
gym you know and I think what does set
Henry sahuda apart from everybody else
is his mindset you know you don't become
a gold medalist in the Olympics a two
Division champion UFC and not have one
of the best mindsets of all time so I
think my his mind is can beat anything
but just with his wrestling background
he's been wrestling since he was two
months old you know that catches up with
you at his age was he 34 32 or some [__]
like that he's getting older you know so
and we know aljo's in his prime so I do
think he's gonna have to battle that I
think he's seen the aljo that he hasn't
seen before he's the three year layoff
but the the one caveat there is Henry
sahuto does have the I think won the
highest of all time IQs as far as inside
that octagon to make changes in between
rounds we've seen it man we've seen
fights go really bad for him and he has
that mental capacity to make the changes
and get it done but I got all the
confidence in aljo though like watching
watching him train
like like sparring five fives and like
I'm just like man this he's he's such a
beast oh he's such a Savage and it
drives me nuts he doesn't get the
respected minus 124 aljo okay so aljo is
a slight favorite minus 125 which is
almost even in MMA but he's a slight
favorite which that that's right because
that's the oddsmaker is going we don't
know what Virgil Henry we're gonna get
you know so at least they got that right
they get that right what else you got
going on the rest of the day my man but
hopefully not no more sparring this week
because it seems like Ray long was a bit
of a old school dude where he makes you
guys uh Spar hard still
yeah yeah he's definitely old school
yeah uh but no no barns Barnes done
um and then yesterday uh was like my
last real hard session I did like a puke
drill
um where it's like a fight simulation
you know I'm hitting pads and then I'm
grappling I'm hitting pads and then I'm
grappling uh doing rounds there you're
doing like one minute grappling one
minute wrestling one minute boxing yeah
it was it's like 30 seconds hidden pads
and then 30 seconds wrestling and 30
seconds hidden pads then maybe a minute
wrestling and uh usually I always we
always do like three five minute rounds
just like the fight
um but I was like I crushed the first
round like I didn't I wasn't really even
that tired and then like Ray comes over
and he's just like like what just just
do do a 10 minute round now you know no
rest
we've like never done that before and I
just look at coach I'm like yeah 10
minute round
so we just crushed the 10 minute round
and that went well for you it went well
yeah boy's in shape it has to give you
confidence man
I know and that's why afterwards he was
like nah you know you're ready for
anything anything that gets thrown at
you yeah
we always kind of mess around I always
have like a schedule you know I kind of
my car coach you know like I tell them
what I like to do like what like what
the plan is and whatnot and uh he kind
of threw a wrench in my plan yesterday
with that 10 minute puke drill round but
you know I I took it in stride and I
crushed it and uh I'm ready for it man
yeah now the the body's there you know
what I'm saying you've put all the work
in it's just this thing with a Drew
Dober fight man let him make the mistake
you know what I'm saying yes yes and
I've been doing my cold plunges getting
my mind hardened again my my body hard
yeah brother yeah I can feel it man and
I I know like you can crack he can crack
at the level you're going to jump in
this top 15 after this everybody can
crack it's the guys that can crack and
then know when to crack you know what
I'm saying that's the difference at the
high level it's the guys that know when
to all right all right I can I can play
a little bit here go back to the game
plan if you see the guys like you know I
love them Cody garbrandt for the longest
man he was that guy and if he got hit he
just he forgot everything all his
trading all his game plan and just fire
off and at a certain level just you
can't win in the UFC at a certain level
you know yeah yeah you sound like Ray
pointing at your head we're using our
head well we'll have to get you uh uh on
a fight companion man fly up from uh out
there in Strong Island get you on a
fight campaign that'd be fun man oh dude
that would be so much fun and then maybe
a food truck too maybe me and marab get
out there oh dude let's do it you marab
you get the squad out there I know I
mean uh Ray's been talking to my team
we're gonna get ray out here too so we
could do the whole Squad man whatever
you want to do but you got my word man
you take care of business Saturday let's
get you on companion food truck whatever
you want brother we'll figure it out oh
dude that's awesome uh I appreciate you
bro yeah of course man been a fan for a
while take care of business Saturday
brother you know who I'm rooting for and
I'll be in touch man
thank you man nice to talk brother good
luck stay shirtless yeah yeah all right
brother take it easy all right chin give
it to me what do we got all right let's
go with uh so Luke rockhold obviously
well you want to go over the uh the bkfc
card real quick
yeah bkfc was the definitely in the news
of the weekend man yeah
I told Matt you know Mike Perry's the
hero we didn't know we needed and Mike
Perry is the herald that bkfc didn't
know was gonna become the face of an
organization you know Mike Perry beat uh
dude it's insane say beat Michael Venom
page yeah that was crazy you know he's
uh now he's beat Luke rockhold now if
these were MMA fights I would not pick
him bear knuckle I'm like I'm taking my
perry he's just a dog like he even uh I
don't think me and count talked about it
when uh on the show but in the back he's
like dude tough fight for Mike Perry off
I'm like listen if it's UFC Luke
rockhold All Day bare knuckle no this is
Mike Perry [__] man this he's just has
this dog in him he was born for Bare
knuckle it's just what he does he does
it better than anybody else on the
planet he's just the guy when it comes
bare knuckle he found his Lane he's the
face of bare knuckle hats off to him you
do not want to fight Mike Perry with
bare Knuckles he broke [__] Luke
rockhold's teeth
he broke his teeth that dude's a model
he went oh your model say less and then
the the the pre-fight interviews are
fantastic look at Luke rockhold looks he
got in a fight with a [__] jet
[__]
lip a little knuckles got me lip busted
teeth broke jaw broke maybe a beard
maybe a better mouthpiece
it's a good fight maybe don't fight beer
knuckles
[__] Mikey tough bastard as tough as
they come congrats
sponsors thing for people
I'm not done
some gloves being nice stuff
this is not done I love Luke I I just
you know I
you know Luke's a dog it's just
Mikey is a complete nightmare of a
matchup for him it's just when he says
he's not done I just he Luke's so
talented you know if you want to come
back to UFC if they'd have him maybe one
off there but it has to be maybe one
more you know but not him better not go
especially with that modeling career son
it's not for you you know yeah then
Eddie Alvarez Chad Mendes geez he's the
same fight yeah that was beautiful
biggest card bare Knuckles had Eddie
Alvarez and Chad Mendez my God I need to
get on whatever Chad's selling on his
freaking uh camping yeah
yeah Peak refuel which is like a you
know dehydrated meals which is about
Sergeant here's what's interesting about
Chad Mendes so you know a guy well
obviously podcast guys parlaying the
podcasting or uh whatever it is you know
outside of fighting merch stuff like
that yeah but quietly Chad Mendes has
created this hunting Empire hunting he's
so successful outside of bare knuckle
bare knuckle for him is just something
to do Financial he's good dude he's a
great success story guys that retired
and went on to do great things because
with that uh what's it called fins and
Feathers fins and Feathers Fins Feathers
and tits dude Fins Feathers tits It's a
strip club where you hunt and kill fish
no uh Chad Mendez has he's a great
hunter right so he has in Fisher so he
has this kind of service we can sign up
to hunt or fish for Chad Mendes it sells
out right away all the way it can't be
cheap then he has his own line of food
when you're hunting down with Peak
refuel yeah his own signature meals
which I buy which by the way they
reached out to us too they're down to
give us stuff take my kids uh camping uh
end of May yeah I rent an RV and I I
just told that the guy didn't accept the
offer so we don't have an RV right now
but I'm gonna find one yeah I'm gonna
find one but I'll take the kids I'll get
I'll load up on some of that Peak
refueling yeah Peak refuel they get like
beef stroganoff make you throw up what I
think about it it's delicious I know I'm
also not a soldier and I wreck right yes
so you know I could just bring some hot
dogs and put them over the flames and
we're also only there for two nights you
know it's not like I'm going on a month
hiking yeah Camp Retreat hunting [__]
Bears where I need
beef stroganoff you know I don't want to
[__] my pants but yeah shout out to Chad
Mendez just doing the damn thing proud
of you buddy uh on 14 back Rollings uh
lost due to a cut and then Ben roethl
Josh Copeland that was I don't know what
Josh was thinking taking that fight you
know I I trained with Josh when he was
he was just friends with Justin Wren it
would come in just for a big body and
actually I know he's in the UFC next
thing I know he's fighting bare knuckle
against Ben Rothwell see from your boy
here Ben roethlis was tough enough in
the UFC let alone beer knuckle good luck
being Ben Rothwell too in bare knuckle
he's killing it he's a [__] caveman
dude
the whole card was good my boy Chris
camozzi Denver's finest got the KO in
the first round bare Knuckles coming up
dude yeah it's fun dude it's a lot of
fun to watch when the card's like this
yeah yeah it was a great card the the
Eddie Alvarez Chad man is just two
knockdowns a piece was insane them boys
were bodied up well freaking Mendez is
just ins it's all that hiking fishing
killing even like Eddie Albert said he
looks like a turtle like the back yeah
looks like a turtle he's like a ninja
turtle jacked all that hiking fishing
yeah that's all it is dude that's all it
is dude I don't know where you're going
with this channel I think it's his
hunting and fishing son of a [__]
uh all right what do you got buddy all
right so this is this is Mike Perry's
interview with Helen Yee afterwards I
think Matt they look like they're in a
high school gymnasium it does he's such
a character I love his personality
Perry was great remember when remember
when Perry came on food truck he was so
fun yeah but he didn't know who's gonna
I'm like What's Next he's a moment for
Diaz but they're trying to get him he
can't he's like they give me a fight man
the final guy here's Luke rockhold
grab a drink kick my feet up I gotta fly
early in the morning you know I'm gonna
go pack my stuff and I'm gonna kiss my
girl I bet man I'm so damn horn man I've
been I've been it's been a while I've
been saving up dog for this I have my
legs in there tonight
he was built for this 100 how cool is it
to see a guy when he finds his true yeah
Lane in life man shout out to Mike Perry
he's the character good person and I
[__] told whenever it was hating on
the guy remember he's going through all
the domestic stuff and he beat up the
guy in the streets or whatever all that
[__] I think domestic but some sort of
street there's some bullshoulder dude
yeah I meant like outside the the ring
the the Octagon there and I was like and
then he had a kid I'm like I'm telling
you you're getting a different Mike
Perry when you have a kid that stupid
Shenanigans [__] boy stuff used to do
that that all goes away they didn't get
a real Mike Perry look at him dude he's
so cool he's the best I remember like
way early on when he fought this guy
named hyung Yu Lim Korean guy and his
Corner was like look at him he because
his eyes were small he's like you can't
even see this so that was like a
controversy back then I was like a
swollen his eyes are Mike's like I think
he's just Asian it was a weird
controversy but then I'm like I'm like
yeah it's not that bad whatever but then
now I grew to love him so much yeah so
yeah such a fun guy
uh so Darren till reacted to the bkfc as
well he said if uh you know remember he
said he would never go to another MMA
organization because he doesn't want to
disrespect yeah yeah so he would go to
bkfc if they made him like a humongous
offer otherwise he's not doing it they
ain't making him with humility plus four
fights in a row for like five LS7 he's
got but where did he living in also what
were we living when you think you'd beat
Mike Perry and bear knuckle
that would be an interesting fight
though yeah I'll tell you how it's gonna
go I mean Mike is killing it killing it
yeah all the end now he has confidence
on his side and he's a world champion
good [__] luck there until that ain't
what you want man we don't need another
L for you
yeah I'd watch it though
um here's some bad announcements Cody
garbrandt there was rumors about him
possibly fighting Dominic Cruz again but
that's apparently that's off the table
that's a bummer that's the fight yeah
exactly Tom Cruise the fight but now
he's fighting this guy Mario Batista and
I looked at so this is Cody's record
it's not been amazing as of late but he
did win his last five years and then
this doesn't fought some monsters in
that of course
any favors there so yeah this guy's
killing itself yeah
um Arnold Allen said that he would like
to fight Brian Ortega it's a great fight
yeah really good fight
uh we're both in the same position we're
looking for a Redemption he's had his
Top Shot I'm still trying to earn mine
that's the guy to put me right back in
there and win there 100 will be back in
the title talk great fight
and I just thought this was funny
because this is Jorge Mazda's take on
Nate Diaz he put what it what it looked
like to me is this dude ran up on Nate
and you've got to respect every threat
it looked like it was self-defense I
just want to say can't run up on people
you can't violate people's personal
space and feel it's cool to get away
with yeah the facts but I'm saying like
you know how he did it to Colby I was
like as he's saying it like the comments
are just going crazy
yeah yeah that was pretty funny someone
said right message wrong messaging
now the comments are funny uh so this
I'm sure you heard about this already
Israel otisanya style Bender he actually
suffered a pretty it looked insane dude
think about them set on this
[__] just before his fight just
and you're fighting a guy who's you've
never beat and he's knocked you out
[__] twice think about the mindset on
Izzy best of all time dude yes 100 I
remember telling you two I was like he
had me pick if it was going to be Alex
or Izzy and I'm like [__] everything saw
me Alex should win but I want easy to
win but if Izzy wins he's gonna change
people's like their their outlook on
life
if he does win he's gonna change like I
have mental blocks I'm sure people have
mental blocks you think you'd never get
over it he inspired me I'm sure like
millions of people out there he's the
biggest star hands down
so this is this sparring this when he
tears it yeah now there's no sound
without that's all right all right so
you'll see here
right oh damn [__] that's bad
and he was screaming in pain and it's
not dirty from that guy he just did that
he's trying to take it down yeah
yeah and then I guess is he pretended
not to feel that much pain after he
screamed because he didn't want people
to freak out his team to freak out about
the you know the injury
does he have to have a serger I don't
think he know I don't know I mean MCL
you can get away with Terry I tore mine
at no surgery yeah yeah I tore my
Meniscus without going into the house on
his Ultimate Fighter meniscus I never
did anything
I still feel a little pain every day I'm
good
I mean we have to jump and stuff it
might [__] me up that might be why I
tear my hamstrings out they're so tight
because it's like overcompensating yeah
I remember crazy do anything athletic
anymore so who gives a [__]
unless you race Chappelle again
I want no part of that yeah okay so I
guess Colby Covington just recently
received his black belt in jiu jitsu
and it's from
what's this guy's name
hold on
well anyways he receives a black belt
from Jiu Jitsu so people are saying how
dangerous he's going to be now because
he you know he's an awesome wrestler
right now he's a black belt in Jiu Jitsu
well he's probably been a black belt
though by the time you get your black
belt you've probably been working on
black belt level for years that's the
way it works so I don't think much
changes here
all right
good for him though
this kind of sucks so Davidson figured
out he can't get medical clearance for
you damn why his eye remember guys his
eye got jacked up by Brian Reynold [__]
so apparently he's still not good enough
to to fight 290. that's a bummer
and let's go let's revisit it we talked
about this on fire on the kid but not
here so the the records that uh Javonte
Davis and Ryan Garcia made as far as the
gate like the fifth highest ever beat
Canelo Mayweather 1.2 pay-per-view buys
is in stage two yeah insane and again
hats off to both guys neither one can
pull this on their own it's that
combination that got this done and by
with them making sure this fight
happened like hats off to them Ryan
Garcia is on fight kaba's fight campaign
this Saturday awesome UC 288 you got
Ryan Garcia that bad mama jamas on fight
campaign so it's gonna be a fun one
I'll give Ryan more credit too on this
whole thing because he's the one that he
had to like compromise all these
different things yeah just to get it
done yeah
all right this is a uh exhibition match
that Floyd Mayweather's gonna do and the
card's gonna be called last names matter
June 11th and he's fighting all lives
matter I know but John Gotti III which
he's a a descendant you know of John
Gotti but uh he doesn't I don't know if
he does boxing but he's like five and
one in MMA
damn Floyd just doing whatever he's like
his dad was John Gotti or what I know so
you're gonna fight him
okay
are we good for John gotta get in the
fight though
for sure
big dudes it's kill or be killed oh not
really
that's weird
all right uh
let's go to oh this is just silly so
there's six power slap athletes that got
suspended because mother all kinds of
stuff like narcotics and steroids and
just a bunch of stuff six out there but
why are they even testing hey why do you
test them they're in rash guards first
of all if they're in rash guards there
should be no testing second of all I
want my slap fighting athletes on map
yeah that makes it more exciting what
are we doing here they're trying to ruin
the sport how dare you it's just funny
that they test them I don't know I don't
know why they test them what are you
doing they should test them and
celebrate like the champion won he was
on meth and Oxycodone in a system zero
hydration you know and in a rash guard
with tits you know it's like right
that's I got this so expect this what
are you doing here
oh this was not you see this dude yeah
so I guess he's the only he's the second
person ever who was untrained in this
this is Tito Ortiz doing this like a
simulator for it's called nastar which
is basically you know for you know space
whatever crap
I'll just play this video for you real
quick his face that someone paused it I
sent to my group chat with Rogan in town
and Eddie I was like Tito's face it's
nuts yeah after seeing this I wouldn't
do that just because I don't want to be
a man with my face like that yeah one
time like oh I'm good
[Music]
that is insane because you're my grandpa
dude that's like a movie character like
an evil movie character yeah it is like
I mean he survived nine G's which is
insane
he goes up that one got me that one got
me yeah
yeah the video is funny they're all 1G
2G they're counting down and his face
just goes a straight mush
all right uh oh Georgie sent me this I
guess Korean zombie is like
a pretty damn good singer I'll just play
a tiny bit because I don't know how much
we could show it's like all cranes can
sing I don't know what the hell it is
this like Korean Idol I don't know what
this is
just play that much oh I was feeling it
dude no but he's good though wow
so you need to start a band a little
K-pop zombie band
dude zombie that'd be a great name of
the actual K-pop band hell yeah the
zombies
and this is Ed from bjpen.com it's
fibration yeah he's looking really cut
now
hold up take the music off what's he
just so jacked bro what's he gonna do I
don't know he's not part of pfl anymore
yeah he's looking like lean and jacked
Jack City
all right dude I think that's it all
right buddy
that's it kids enjoy the fights this
weekend you have one Championship going
down on May 5th that's Friday live on
Amazon Prime that ridiculous Fight Card
DJ Marias uh the third fight Rod tank
Mikey mushumeshi the pizza expert stamp
fair tax Robert Sol ditch you got Sage
Northcutt RDR you know the Croatian
RoboCop doing the damn thing that's all
going down this Friday on Amazon Prime
video make sure you tune into that then
Saturday UFC 288 we're doing a live
Calabasas fight campaign with George
Janko you got uh Ryan Garcia myself and
another very special guest that's live
at 7 p.m Pacific Time on thick boy
YouTube make sure you tune in because
you're gonna get a lot of fun a lot of
chaos when you got Matt Steamroller for
Rolla versus Drew Dober Chrome Gracie
Bryce Mitchell flat earther Jessica
andrej Muhammad Gilbert Burns Al Joe and
Henry sahudo it's all going Down live 7
P.M Pacific Time on thick boy YouTube
Kyle bass fight companion UFC 288 get
you some all right kids as far as
touring goes uh I'll be doing spots
around La in May and then I think it's
May 19th I'll be at the Ice House
shopping friends those tickets just went
on sale today once you're only shopping
friends at the Ice House in Pasadena
then June 2nd through the 4th that's a
Friday Saturday Sunday I'm at The Comedy
Store in La Jolla and then uh in June
I'm jumping across the pond starts in
Belfast June 15th then we're off to
Glasgow June 17th Manchester June 18th
London June 22nd Cardiff June 23rd then
we end in Dublin my favorite June 25th
All Right tickets at thinkboy.com and
new tiger thick merch drops this Friday
as well on thickboy.com if you haven't
got tiger thick yet it's available right
now we all new pricing we finally
negotiate the price down 59.99 get you
some of that sweet award-winning thick
nectar all right kids but uh I saw May
19th La Jolla see you June 2nd through
the 4th now I'm off to Europe starting
Belfast June 15th love you kids enjoy
the fights if you're in Denver for one
Championship come say hi to your boy all
right love you guys be safe see ya
the greatest of all time here we go the
Epic Trilogy fight for the first time
ever Demetrius Johnson defends the one
flyweight World Championship in the USA
one fight night 10. Johnson versus
Mariah's three on Prime video